uh let's see who else we can go to here
oh you know what let's go to ronald
reagan who is going to uh uh
chime in ronald what's going on hey
david can you hear me i can hey
uh really good quality on these discord
calls pristine incredible
pristine you know there's some other
shows out there that haven't figured out
the
the calling systems but is that right
i've never heard of those i've never
seen those shows
we don't need to go into that but um i
wanted to ask you about the
the limitations of the the sort of obama
uh they go low we go high philosophy
right and how
you know obama came in and did the sort
of gerald ford thing with
you know looking forward not looking
back and treating his uh
predecessor as you know very hands-off
um kid gloves and then
i'm just i'm wondering if all of this
stuff about
trying to like because i think if it
were up to trump he would literally put
obama in jail
yeah and going after their kids you know
trying to get
their kids put in jail and
i i don't see that you know sadly from
my perspective
lighting a fire under under these people
in terms of like
you know changing that sort of dynamic
of
of looking forward and not looking back
i understand there's like some
slippery slope arguments about what
happens in
you know uh sort of banana republics
where you're just constantly throwing
the last president in jail
on trump charges like i understand that
um
fear but i don't know what do you think
about the sort of limitations
of this philosophy and whether or not
you think
that might change moving forward given
the you know what's happened over the
last four years
it it may change but i really just don't
see any way
in which a democratic president is going
to when we talk about when they go low
we go high i think that you you
essentially need context and so i'll
give you examples where you have to just
apply critical thinking
um trump says let's jail biden
the counter would be if biden wins try
to get
trump jailed i think that that is that
is a losing strategy i don't i don't
that that i don't think is is
what we should do but to give you a
counter example
i believe that the public the uh
campaign finance system we have should
be changed
as long as it's the system we have do i
think
democrats should raise as much money as
they can
and spend it on campaign ads which we
know work and do everything they can to
use that system to get into power
of course of course at a certain point
you're talking about you know
uh um unilateral disarmament
uh should negative ads work do i think
on principle biden shouldn't do negative
ads about trump because i don't really
think that that type of
campaigning should be part of our system
no biden's got to use negative ads and
i'm
perfectly fine with him doing it for for
as long as it's the system we have
what you're talking about about you know
starting to to say oh now that i'm
president i'm going to direct attorney
general whoever works for biden
to try to look at jailing trump i i
don't i just don't see even what the
political benefit is to doing that
raygun yeah sorry you cut out there for
a second oh
um yeah no i but i guess
maybe more specifically like do you
think um
do you think they continue like i'm just
thinking about like uh
michelle obama like holding hands with
george w bush
at a i don't remember even his funeral
that was maybe bush senior but
um do you think that there's even like
an attitude
shift in in treating you know trump as a
legitimate
president or do you think they're going
to just continue with that
that i really hope that we don't see and
there's a lot of people who
understandably
see michelle obama talking about how
she's great friends with george w
bush and then they say guy's a war
criminal who made foreign policy
decisions that led to the deaths of what
hundreds of thousands or even more in in
iraq
she's rehabilitating the image of a of a
war criminal
and i think that that is legitimate and
at the same time
this is a very small group of former
presidents and what
what do you expect to happen for such a
small club
i hope that that does not happen with
donald trump because i see donald trump
as such a different animal in many ways
that than the others i i i don't want
democrats to do that and i hope that
they don't
right thanks dude all right by the way
raygun you still there
yeah quick question do you know you're a
lawyer do you know what this greatest
political crime in history that trump is
talking about that was committed by
obama and biden is do you know what law
might have been broken
uh they they spied on his campaign
campaign david i mean you should know
that you're
you report the news they spied on his
campaign
and uh they abused um fisa
i've heard yeah and um
[Music]
you know it's just it yeah it's like
watergate but worse
it's worse than watergate yeah all right
raygun thank you very much great to hear
from you
i'm sorry i can't take any more calls
today but i did what i could we will
take a quick break and take
calls again very very soon one of our
sponsors today
is vincero watches and they're giving
you 15
off everything in the store when you go
to davidpakman.com
watch if you're a guy looking for the
perfect way
to refresh your style one of the best
investments you can make is in a high
quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about 200
but it'll look like you spent a lot more
all of their watches are made in small
batches from top quality materials
and they just look great i went on their
site and picked out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 off everything in their
store
when you go to davidpakman.com watch and
i've put that link right underneath this
video